Speaker 1: OK, one little funny
like coda onto the Canadian trucker
story. A MyPillow CEO, Mike Lindell, has been
barred from entering Canada. This is it's
you couldn't script it. You couldn't script it.
If you if you included this in a screenplay of
this entire thing, it would be silly now. It's
not believable. Mike Pillow, as we know him,
has been on this propaganda campaign to deliver
pillows to the truckers. OK. And he sent a truck,
which I guess got held up at the border, some some
kind of customs thing. But then Pillow tried to go
to Canada, and he was turned away because he was
not fully vaccinated and didn't have a negative
PCR test, according to a government source. It's
beyond parody, and he knew the rules. Or at least
he should've known the rules if he didn't. And
of course, this was what was going to happen.
But he was not allowed into Canada. The funniest
thing would have been if he did get allowed in
because he actually is vaccinated. You know
how some of these right wingers, I mean,
Eric Trump we looked at earlier in the show. They
attack vaccines. They criticize vaccines, but
they're almost certainly all vaccinated.
It would have been like the perfect
cherry on top if pillow was actually vaccinated,
despite claiming to be against the vaccine. And
the latest thing that he's going to try
to do is to drop the pillows from the sky
to the truckers after his initial Tuesday shipment
of MyPillow products was denied entry into Canada.
Pillow now has a backup plan to get the
pillows to the truckers, drop them from the sky
via a helicopter. It's not clear that that's
actually even going to be a possibility as well.
The Mike Pillow thing is it's a tragic comedy. It
really is. Like all he had to do was keep selling
pillows on TV and he would be doing fine, but he
had to mix politics. He's making commercials now
about being canceled. His bank has canceled his
account because of reputational damage that they
worry about. And I got a ton of messages from
Canadians in our audience saying, David, please
keep your nut jobs in the United States. I have
no interest in sending pillow to Canada. Trust me,
I have nothing to do with this, but just the final
sort of bizarre detail with the Mike Pillow saga.